voici ce qui reste de l'appareil boeing
737 quelques minutes à peine après son
décollage de l'aéroport de téhéran d'où
ce matin des débris et des passagers en
proie des flammes
un brasier si intense que les
secouristes ont été incapables d'en
sortir qui que ce soit vivant
c'est une fois le soleil levé que
l'ampleur de la catastrophe c'est
confirmé il n'y a aucun survivant
176 personnes étaient à bord l'avion se
dirigeait vers kiev mais la grande
majorité des voyageurs il faisait
seulement escale avant de poursuivre
leur chemin vers le canada 63 était
d'ailleurs des citoyens canadiens
parmi les autres disparus 82 étaient des
iraniens dit suédois quatre afghans des
allemands et des britanniques
et tout l'équipage du cri ni
à l'aéroport de kiev les employés
étaient sous le choc des familles
incrédule en sanglots visiblement secoué
le président du transporteur ukrainian
internationals airlines expliqué que
l'équipage était des plus expérimentés
l'appareil un boeing 737-800 était non
seulement un des meilleurs de leur
flotte
il était neuf et avait passé avec succès
une révision technique le 6 janvier
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé les
autorités iraniennes priorise la thèse
d'une défaillance catastrophique des
moteurs de l'avion mais l'ukraine écarte
pour le moment aucun scénario
cette boule de flux est bel et bien
l'appareil qui se dirige vers le sol
quatre minutes après le décollage ou que
signal de détresse n'a été envoyé
l'avion a simplement disparu des radars
jetterait dire le premier ministre
ukrainienne a refusé de commenter les
informations selon lesquelles l'appareil
aurait pu être abattu par des missiles
visant les forces américaines en irak
mais par mesure de précaution il
explique que toutes les compagnies
ukrainiennes ont reçu l'ordre d'éviter
l'espace aérien l'iran et ce jusqu à
nouvel an l'enquète se poursuit
l'ukraine participera officiellement une
équipe a été dépêché d'urgence à téhéran
où les boîtes noires de l'appareil ont
été récupérées et seront analysées sous
peu c'est donc officiel l'ukraine va
participer à cette enquête crucial mais
pour le moment les autorités iraniennes
refuse catégoriquement de laisser le
fabricant américain boeing collaborer ce
qui ajoute au climat de méfiance qui
entoure cette tragédie aérienne dans une
région qui sera dorénavant éviter par
les plus grands transporteurs du monde y
compris air canada lufthansa et aeroflot
de russie tant et aussi longtemps que
les doutes persistent rond
quant aux risques de la survoler et si
thammarat alter escaut radio-canada
moscou